simple simple stuff okay what was the
point of that well what point out to you
is the thing I'm actually not interested
in is is the numbers which is why the
numbers are all very simple numbers the
thing is I'm really interested in are
the signs okay
so for example I want you to have a look
at these to you these to you
do you see that what they have in common
is that all three numbers at the
beginning all three numbers they're all
positive you notice that right so
positive and positive right then when
you multiply three positive numbers
together it doesn't matter if they're
all one or if they're all two or if
they're all different or if they're all
whatever okay you know and at the end
what you must end up with is also
positive do you agree with that and
there are no negatives that can get of
looking okay it's never gonna sneak up
on you somehow positive times positive
times positive will always end up with
positive that okay all right now you can
see I've got some patterns coming up
here as well right
these next two right positive negative
positive if there's just one negative
hiding in there somewhere right maybe
you know whatever the numbers are I
don't care what the size of the numbers
are I care at the signs of the numbers
not the size at the site you're always
going to get well if I have a positive
negative and a positive the sign of my
answer will be negative right does that
make sense
couple more just a minute you can see if
I've got two negative positive negative
positive negative then my answer those
two negatives are going to cancel out
and then my last one if I've got three
negatives then of course my final and so
what I've multiplied everything together
will be negative okay now this partner
here right or if there's an odd number
of negatives like 103 it's an odd number
then my ads will be negative okay this
is enormous ly useful when we come to
graph okay
so here's what I want you to look at
remember we took these two graphs here
okay when we divided up into factors we
divided up into X minus 4 and X plus 3
okay we can graph those factors on to
our original graph okay so for example
with my we might fix up with intercepts
thank you very much okay um y equals X
minus 4 if I just ask you to graph that
line alone where it belong on my graph
where'd it go it's going to be passing
through this intercept isn't it right
and y equals x it's just going to be
increasing up like this so go back to
your original graph and if you have a
different color or if you haven't if you
only have like a pencil just do this
lightly I want you to draw the line y
equals x minus 4 on top of your parabola
okay y equals X minus 4 and this is not
the graph that I'm actually wanting
I want the whole parabola right but this
is a factor line of the graph X minus 4
is a factor and that is the line that
represents the factor okay now that was
X minus 4 I also have X plus 3 on there
right what is that factor like
it's um it's gonna posture the other
into sense right like this guy over here
X plus three that's what it looks like I
know because it's like X but three unit
I'm okay now he's how I'm going to use
these two factor lines right
remember I said okay these are these are
with three that was a tribute example if
I've got two negative numbers two
negative numbers and I don't know what
their sizes are if I multiply them
together the product of two negative
numbers will always be what sign does it
have it will always be positive right so
can you see this blue line really comes
from take this green line this factor
and multiply it by this Green Line which
is the other factor that's what this
says right so over here have a look over
here to the left of x equals negative
three just over here okay do you see
that one of my factors is negative and
the other factor is also negative do you
see that so I've got two factors and it
both negative but you just told me the
negative times a negative is positive
right so therefore I know my actual
graph should pass through up here in
this positive area up here let me stand
it again right these two negative
factors there they are factor factor and
there are the lines that represent them
when you multiply them together you
should get something positive which in
fact is what I get
that's my parabola you guys do that from
the beginning okay once I cross over
this line I go from Dave left of
negative three to the right of negative
three
what are we two factors doing what are
the signs of the two factors in this
skin between space do you see ones
positive and ones negative once above
the axis of ones below so if you must
apply a puzzie number to negative F up
what will the sign of the result be here
we made it positive times there's only
one they did so negative is under the
axis so my actual graph has to pass
through this region and just shaded
which indeed it does because we knew
prevalent right last one have a look at
the right-hand side once I cross over
this factor positive and this guy's also
positive clearly positive right so
positive type positive ears so I up here
which of course is what the parabola
does right so you can see one two three
had I'm not know it was a parabola
had it been like some reader looking
shape right I can know it has to pass
through these gray shaded regions okay
maybe do one more time I'll do it a
little bit quicker for this one and then
we're gonna do one without knowing what
the graph actually looks like one two
three
there are my factors right so we'll buy
factor let's go wipers X that just coast
in your room right y equals x plus two
is gonna go through that my wife whose x
plus three will go than that
here are my one two three factors okay
I'm going to draw some vertical lines
through the places where those factors
change so I go from negative to positive
now look with me right the whole graph I
dropped it off of the home graph here
right it's made up of these three
factors that over here on the Left what
are the signs of all three of my factors
they're all naked you see they're all
below the axis one two three they're all
under here which is negative so negative
x negative x negative of course it is
three negatives it's an odd number of
negatives so that'll be negative yeah so
I'm down here I cross over right when I
go from here to here
I still have three factors but look to a
negative and one is positive you see
that to Bombay actors now sorts negative
times negative times positive it's
positive
okay in fact you can see I don't need to
ask this question anymore
every time I go past a boundary I change
sign I got a negative positive my next
one is obviously going to be negative
and then my last one it's positive right
so I have these four regions that my
graph has to pass through one two three
four which indeed is what that graph was
doing you can see the blue line we drew
the first place